hey guys this is Vadim and welcome to
max tech so it's been 10 years since
Apple released the original MacBook Air
and it hasn't changed a single time
until now Apple's new 2018 MacBook Air
has been completely redesigned to look
more like their 12-inch MacBook and it
all looks great except for a few things
that are keeping me from buying it right
now people bought the original MacBook
for a few different reasons one it was
cheap it was thin it was light it had
lots of ports and had great battery life
now the biggest problem with the new
2018 MacBook Air is that it costs $200
more than it did before making it only
$100 cheaper than the 13-inch MacBook
Pro and the 12-inch MacBook now I agree
that the new MacBook Air is better than
the 12-inch MacBook in basically every
way except it's a little bit thicker and
it's a little bit heavier the 13-inch
MacBook Pro is better in a few ways
which I'll get into in just a bit now I
personally think that Apple really
should have priced this at a maximum of
1099 because $11.99 is way too expensive
and it's way too close to the other
devices on to the second problem there's
only two ports they're both Thunderbolt
three ports which is really nice but the
old MacBook Air had a ton of ports and
this one just has two ports and you're
gonna need adapters for all your legacy
devices so that is a major issue for all
the casual users of course Thunderbolt 3
is nice because you can hook up really
fast drives you can hook up a 5k
external display and a bunch of other
stuff but the market that the MacBook
Air is targeted to doesn't really need
this stuff at all and the people who do
need those ports are just gonna go with
the 13-inch MacBook Pro anyways or maybe
even the 2018 MacBook Pro that starts at
$17.99 that's personally what I would
choose so overall a lot of the regular
consumers are gonna have big issues with
the two u.s. PC ports now onto the third
problem the MacBook Air is still packin
a dual-core processor while the rest of
the market is moving to four cores
I'm really not sure why Apple's stuck
with the dual core now I know that it
helps with battery life but it would
have been really nice to have that extra
upgrade option to a quad-core yes it
matches the 13-inch MacBook Pros turbo
boost of 3.6 gigahertz but the core
clock speed is a lot slower and it's a 7
watt chip instead of a 15 watt chip so
it's gonna draw a lot less power and
it's ultimately going to be slower not
only that but the new MacBook Airs
Fix performance is much worse than the
13-inch MacBook Pros in fact the MacBook
Pro gets 50 percent faster graphics
performance now of course that's why
it's called the MacBook Pro but if you
check B&H it's only fifty dollars more
than the new MacBook Air for all the
extra power sure the target market
doesn't really need the extra power but
for me personally that's the only reason
why I haven't already ordered the
MacBook Air now onto the fourth reason
even though the new MacBook Air has a
Retina display it's actually worse than
the 13-inch MacBook Pros Retina display
the pro gets a brighter 500 nits display
which really helps we're using it
outside in the daylight or even in a
really bright room the pro also gets P
three wide color gamut support so it's
got much better color accuracy compared
to the air this is yet another reason to
choose the pro over the air for just $50
more for the fifth and final problem the
new MacBook Air is still using Bluetooth
4.2 basically every single 2018 Apple
device except for the budget iPad has
now moved on to Bluetooth 5 including
all the new iPhones the home pod the
Apple TV 4k the Mac Mini the MacBook
Pros and the new iPad pro since
everything else is moving on to
Bluetooth 5 it really sucks that Apple
chose to keep the macbook air at
bluetooth 4.2 of course it's not that
big of a deal yet because there isn't
that mini bluetooth 5 devices out there
but it's still a big deal to me so there
you have it guys that's the top 5
problems with the new MacBook Air thanks
for watching this video guys make sure
to leave a comment below and subscribe
for more videos like this one